good morning
good afternoon and to some of you good
evening i'm christy jewell of labyrinth
and i'd like to welcome you to today's
live webinar
unveiling the role of t-cell dysfunction
in the development and progression of
glioblastoma
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots
and sponsored by gibco by thermo fisher
scientific
gibco cell culture heroes is a program
putting phd and postdoc researchers
around the world
in the spotlight for more information on
our sponsor please visit
thermofisher.com forward slash cell
culture heroes
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that today's event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate
by submitting as many of the as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click
send you can also see at the top of the
page
multiple tabs please click through our
related
applications upcoming and on-demand
webinars as well as links
to the cell culture heroes webpage you
may be our next cell culture hero
also please notice you can share this
webinar on your personal social media
just click on the social sharing tab to
let your friends and colleagues know
about today's live event
now if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation just click on
that support tab found at the top right
of your presentation window
or you can let us know your experiencing
problem by using that ask a question box
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
your presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i would now like to introduce our
presenter dr felipe galvez cansino
post doctoral researcher for a complete
biography on dr galvez casino
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr galvez casino you may now begin your
presentation
okay so thank you very much i'm philippe
gardius
i'm a postdoctoral researcher at ucl
cancer institute
i'm going to talk about the role of the
tissue dysfunction in glioblastoma
so the topics i'm going to discuss today
is basically i'm going to give an
overview of the immune response
against tumors and the current state of
immunotherapy
i'm gonna give an overview about the
current about our current understanding
of the new microenvironment of
glioblastoma
i'm gonna share some preliminary data
regarding
the pseudo-characterization we have done
optimum microbind of one of our mouse
models of glioblastoma
and finally i will discuss our rational
approach for the discovery of novel
targets for immunotherapy
so when we talk about the immune
surveillance against tumors
we we can we have to start by talking
about
we have a tumor and these tumors have
cells that are constantly dying
and these cells can be captured by
immature dendritic cells
yeah and in this immature dendritic
cells will capture
cells that contains cells and neo
antigens that come from cells
and in mutation the right protein
so these dendritic cells will migrate to
the
draining lymph nodes and once in the
draining lymph nodes
they will present peptides derives from
these
cells and neoantigens to uh knight
cd4 and cd8 t cells in a three signal
dependent
uh mechanism so that includes
uh antipresentation through mhctc
t-cell receptor and co-stimulation
and the production of cytokines so these
t-cells will proliferate
and at the end and particularly cd8
theses will become
effectors and they are the main
responsibles of killing the tumor
however the tumor can stop
cva diesel by using
two main molecules so the tumor can
easily
express pdl1 and these
as they get activated they express a
molecule that
stops their activity called td1
and already like almost 10 years ago
so these types are already known so
people realize that by blocking this
signal
with an antibody against pv one with a
nand spot against pdr1
so people show up so these researchers
show
amazing results in patients with
melanoma
tumors within with huge remissions of
the tumors that
associated with infiltration of
cytotoxic
cvh t-cells so now another
correlation that people found is
basically that the amount of mutations
of the tumor predict of the efficacy of
immunotherapy
and tumors with highest amount of
mutations
were more responsive to
immunotherapy than those with less
amount of mutations
and more interestingly subsequent
studies showed that the presence of
antigens right from these mutations that
could be recognized by pisons
predict the survival of this space of
patients with non-small cell lung cancer
melanoma and other type of tumors
and these patients that were surviving
to following these therapies
have a huge amount of severe disorders
in the tumors and that these ca thesis
were recognizing
mutant peptides derived from proteins
in these tumors so if we want to
understand
how the subsidiaries of response work
so we can graph the
time versus the amount of cd-18 cs
cd8 off so we can imagine that in the
case of an infection a vaccination or
even a tumor so
cd8 diseases are in a naive state and
once they recognize their
antigen they start proliferating and
they become
effectors and we can talk about memory
precursors and
effector cells so once the antigen
disappears so the infection goes away or
the tumor
goes away most of these cells
die however a fraction of these cells
survive
and become memory t-cells the problem
with tumors
is that tumors don't go away and the
andean
keeps in the system and what happens is
basically that
these cvi t cells keep recognizing the
tumor
and they become dysfunctional
so one of the big questions in the field
today
is what how does this dysfunction
works so what we know so far
is basically that c8t cells recognize
the
tumor cell and they recognize these
tumor cells
in a chronic way so this they are
constantly seeing the same antigen and
we have a chronic
t-cell receptor stimulation and this
chronic
t-cell receptor stimulation drives
several transcription factors that
finally result in the increase of pd1
tin 3 and several inhibitor receptors
that their function is basically avoid
the overstimulation of these cells that
could
produce the death of these cells and
promote their survival
the problem is that this way to survive
place a dysfunctional state of these
cells that
avoid them to kill the tumor
and the obvious question of this
presentation is what happens in
glioblastoma
so when we think of glioblastoma we are
thinking
of several types of disease and very
complex
uh with very complex classification
so in very simple words biolastoma
is a type is a subject of diffuse
gliomas
so basically any tumor that resembles
a glial cell and this there are
several type of uh diffuse gliomas
but the ones we are focusing our
research is particularly
ivh multiplioblastomas which are the
ones with the
worst survival of all brain cancers
and when we look inside glioblastomas we
can
divide these tumors based on their
mutations
and already 10 years ago
several authors classified these tumors
in three main subsets based on the type
of mutations they have
so we can easily distinguish pro neural
tumors
based in the mutation of p53
and pdgfr tumors with a classical
uh genotype based on the
uh deletion of cdkm2a
and the exp the os the amplification of
egfr or the expression of efrb3
and also a mesenchymal subtype of
glioblastoma
characterized by the loss of p53 and the
loss of
nf1 and very interestingly 10 years ago
it was also in the same paper it was
described that this
subset of glioblastoma predicts the
response
to chemo and value therapy in patients
so we can
clearly see that classical glioblastomas
so patients that have tumors and rich in
in this classical genotype tensor tend
to respond better to
these therapies so today the obvious
question is
what could happen uh with immunotherapy
will these patients respond the same
with this patient
with patients that have in which one of
these substances will respond better
so and also for very long time it has
been believed that glioblastoma
has a very poor infiltration of immune
cells
so in 20 in in
some time ago so people start looking to
the
to the tcga to the cell cancer genome
atlas
looking for uh signatures of immune
cells
and actually there are signatures of
immune cells and what they also
found is basically that you can find
signatures of cva t
cells nyx cd4 t cells regulatory c for t
cells macrophages monocytes
and nk cells among others
and more recently others from
taking tumors for single cell
rna sequencing they they found that
there is a small but very
frequent amount of t-cells in these
tumors
so where what's the question of
glioblastoma is regarding what i've
talked here so
basically the question we have in the
question we are pursuing is basically
so glioblastoma has t cells and the
question
is basically does t-cell dysfunctions
occur
in glioblastoma in this type of tumor
that have
so few mutations compared to others like
melanoma and non-cellular cancer and if
there is a dysfunction function in
bioblastoma the next question is can we
modulate this
state in order to generate neural
immunotherapies for this disease
so we are approaching this problem
through a mouse model
of this disease so our mouse model
is what we call an orthotopic mouse
model where we can
implant glioblastoma cells in the brain
of mice and three weeks later we can
analyze these tumors by flucidometry
so the characteristics of this mouse
model that
we have developed and analyzed in
collaboration with
steep polar in the university of
edinburgh
is basically that this cell line is
derived from neural stem cells and it
carries
the same mutations as the human disease
we are working with a mole that
is nf1 knockout pizza and knockout
and it overexpressed egfr v3
and the cool thing about this model is
that we can practice model
in vivo and if we get the brain
we can also see the tumor under the
microscope which allow us to
cut the tumor and analyze specifically
the immune microenvironment
inside this tissue so
what we have seen is basically if we
analyze the brain of a mouse without a
tumor
we can see as it has been described that
a normal brain is dominated by
microglias
in this dimension reduction called umap
where we can observe all the immune
populations that reside
in a normal brain we can see
in purple that the main population that
resides
in a normal brain are microglia
so but the question is what happens in
our mouse multiplioblastoma
so if we cut specifically the tumor
we can see that the glioblastoma tumor
is enriched on myelin cells particularly
macrophages and also it has
a t-cell population
they are characterized by the
infiltration of c force and cva t cells
and if we quantify the proportion of
these
uh of these cells and we look first
at the innate compartment that
compromise uh
mileage cells and entry cells we can see
that in the tumor it looks like
microlias tend to disappear
but we believe we haven't done uh uh a
deep characterization of this
we believe that it is more like
microless tend to change their phenotype
and they tend to look more like
macrophages and we can see that
macrophages
are increased and anti-cells are
also increased inside the tumor and when
we look at the decent compartment
we can clearly see that there is an
increase
on cd4 effector t-cells c
for t-rex and c-d-a t-cells yeah
so we see that there is an infiltration
of
several type of cells in this tumor so
the next question
we ask is what's the phenotype of these
cells
so we perform a differential state
analysis
of these of these three groups
so we compare the two more against the
control
and the control brain and the
non-involved tissue which is
the the healthy tissues around the tumor
and what we can see
very clearly is that the the cells that
accumulate in a significant weight
inside the tumor is basically
macrophages
and also we can clearly see subset of
cd8
and cd for dissonance which are pd1
positive
which is a marker of as i already
explained you
of this function or pieces which are
activated
and these sounds are p1 positive k67
negative so it means that they are
probably too more reactive
for some way we don't understand they
are expressing p1
but and they are not proliferating and
we can clearly see
that near cvh or c4s are proliferating
in our model
and when we quantify this we can by
looking at pd1 versus k60 we can clearly
see
an increase on cells which are
uh pd1 positive k67 negative
suggesting that for some reason we still
are trying to understand these cells
accumulate in the tumor they express pd1
but they stop proliferating so they are
probably
entering in a quiescent or dysfunctional
state
and more interestingly when we look at
the expression of
all markers of exhaustion classic
markers of exhaustion such as slack 3
team 3 we can see that most of these
cells
are negative for these markers so what
we believe is that
in glioblastoma t cells enter in a
very particular state of dysfunction
that could be different from what we
have seen in other type of tumors
and in order to validate our results we
we went
into human data and we look at the
public data sets
so we look at a data set of
several type of tumors that was recently
published
in nature amazing generally of this year
so
we took this data we are we reanalyze it
and for example if we look at renal cell
carcinoma and non-small cell lung cancer
we can see that most of the disease are
in a state
where they are pd1 nki 67 double
positive
which means that they are exhausted but
or they are recognizing their antigen in
the tumor
but they are proliferating so now what
happens if we look at
bioblastoma what we can see is that
this population that was very abundant
in
in renal cell carcinoma and lung cancer
which was that
this pd1 case central positive
population
it is not that abundant glioblastoma and
as it was in our mouse model the
population that tend to be
more abundant is this regulation of pd1
positive cases and
negative cells so
now the question we are pursuing in the
lab
is basically how can we reverse
these dysfunctional states of these
and that's the question that many people
is asking today
so we believe that one way to do this
is using gene editing by crispr
so as you might know crispr cast 9 is a
gene editing technique that allows to
very easily target a gene
and knock out this skin in any in
any and any type of cell
so very recently people have done this
on this one so
this is from the group of a group in new
york
they took t-cells they realized they did
something beautiful they took these
t-cells they redirect these tissues
against a tumor antigen
and they knock out pd-1 and then
they reinjected these t-cells into
patients with cancer
so this was the first study using
gene edited immune cells to treat
cancer okay this was a very small study
with uh without positive results but it
was
groundbreaking because it was the first
time to do this
in human sense and to apply it to
patients
yeah so basically how and but we are
interested
in discovering new regulators of diesel
function
and use this to uh
to to avoid this and dysfunction to
recover these dysfunctional states
that diesels undergo in the tumor so
people how do people discover new
targets so what people does and what
everybody in the field is doing they
usually take
human pieces that can eat tumor
infiltrated lymphocytes it's very flat
or
peripheral blood and mononuclear cells
they uh do crispr casino on those cells
they knock out
any gene they think that could be
relevant and then they do
a functional assay so in that functional
assay
are usually acids where they make the
systems proliferate
or recognize a tumor as they think
it could be in the human tissue
then they analyze this by
single cell rna sequencing and they
identify
which gain could be relevant the problem
with this approach
that we believe is not good at all
it's basically that everybody is
discovering the same targets
so what we believe is that this classic
approach of discovering novel regulators
of fiscal function
leads to the identification the
identification of
assay dependent genes so as people uses
functional assets that are related to
cell proliferation
most of the people discover the same
genes related to cell proliferation
so we've taken thinking of this we're
taking a more
rational approach and what we have done
so with this is data from lung cancer
and we are trying to apply to
glioblastoma
so what we have done is doing single
cell rna
sequencing from a lung cancer
tumors so from lung tumors
we analyze the from t cells in these
tumors
we analyze the the transcriptome of
these t-cells
and then we specifically look for genes
that could be
driving this dysfunctional state on t
cells
and what we expect is that this approach
this more
rational approach could lead to a better
discovery
of targets for immunotherapy that can be
used to reverse
peace on this function so and i want to
show you
just one example of our rational
approach
and how powerful it can be so one of
our targets which is a regulator of
of the t cell receptor a negative
regulator of the diesel receptor
what we have seen is basically that when
we knock out
one this target we can see a huge
increase
in the production of interferon gamma
on city force and cd8 t-cells so
just by using this approach and just by
targeting one of our
more than 100 targets that we have
identified by using single cell rna
sequencing
we can already find a molecule
that can be used to reverse a
dysfunctional state on
diesels so to finish
i would like to give some conclusions so
basically
i'd like to say that glioblastoma due to
its impressive
capacity to start the immune response
represents
a huge opportunity to understand the
underlying mechanisms of these
dysfunction also i would like to say
that crispr
mediated gene 18 will allow us to
genetically modify seasons and make them
resistant to this function
and this definitely holds promise for
the development of novel
adoptive cell therapies for glioblastoma
and finally what i would like to say is
that immunotherapy
whole promise for treating glioblastoma
it hasn't been successful
yet but we are sure that by
targeting diesel dysfunction and or mild
cells
uh it could be the next generation of
immunotherapies that will definitely
work for glioblastoma
so finally i would like to acknowledge
to
my laboratory to my mentor sergio
quesada
to my collaborators in
in edinburgh and here in london thank
you very much
thank you dr galvez castino for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of our webinar
now to our audience if you have a
question you would like to ask please do
so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
okay let's get started we have some
great questions already coming in
let's start with this one why do you
think
that t cells stop proliferating in the
tumor
microenvironment oh
okay thank you thank you for the
question
so what we believe is this is probably
something very unique of glioblastoma
tumors
the more than tissues becoming exhausted
in the
micro environment they are likely to
stop proliferating
and we believe that they they tend to
stop proliferating
and because due to the lack of resources
that they need to proliferate
so one of the things we are exploring
right now and that can be eventually
interesting
as a therapy is basically
using uh so we believe that probably
the lack of i interleukin 2 which is key
for the proliferation of t cells of the
lack
of isl and il15 is probably driving this
this loss of proliferation on pistols so
what we believe is basically that if we
can in some way
give il2 in a in a
in a way that is not toxic or maybe
also give il-7 and il-15 which are key
cytokines
relevant for pc proliferation and the
generation of memory diesels
could be a way to generate like new
therapies for
for glioblastoma we cover this uh
this dysfunctional state of t cells
thank you now dr galvez can she know
how do you plan to use gene edited t
cells for treating
glioblastoma yeah so that
that's particularly challenging nowadays
but what people
is doing and what we believe it will be
the feature of this therapist
is trying to take t-cells from the
the patient of the from the tumor of the
patients expand these tissues
in vitro and then edit
this cells in the lab in the laboratory
and then reinfuse these diesels into the
patients
this is something that has worked
already in tumors like melanoma
and lung cancer is called a adopted
piece of therapy
and that's a way to to use gene-edited
teasons for creating
uh for eventual triumph glioblastoma
in any tumor the other way to to
to use gene education could be using car
t
cells that is known that these
cartesians
actually give something give some
benefit to
to patients with glioblastoma and we
could
edit these cartesians and reinfuse them
into patients that's something that
probably there is people doing it
yeah and what we plan is to use one of
these strategies
and but using our our
targets that we have discovered
which molecule do you think is most
promising about
t cell dysfunction
okay so that depends so molecule for
like as a therapy i think there is a
a lot of molecules that are very
promising but
i think what we have to look for is a
molecule that
can avoid tissue dysfunction without
making the cells
uh dying for example recently that was
described a transcription factor that
drives diesel dysfunction but when the
elders of the study knock out the
transcription factor
all cells die so in some way tissue
dysfunction
is needed because it it's avoid the
cells to become
over-activated and die so what we need
is for example looking for a molecule
like a negative regulator of the t-cell
receptor
so if we can make the t-cell receptor
more sensitive to anterior stimulation
and that drive like this activation in a
more physiological way
to be a good target that's something
that has been also recently published
for example nicolas restifo
uh last week published a paper
analyzing uh several
regulators of the t-cell receptor and
they found that
if you can knock out one of those i
think it was p38
you can make pieces that have a memory
phenotype
they are high defector and they do not
differentiate and become like terminally
differentiated quickly
thank you have you looked at macrophages
status in tme
yeah we are doing that so we are
we are using this orthotopic mouse model
i just
showed and to look at that and we are
also using some uh something we call
then normal tumor models where the tumor
develops
very slowly in a more physiological way
and we have look at macrophages
they look so they look very interesting
we are also interested in developing
traffic start using macrophages
and it makes sense it makes a lot of
sense with what have recently described
by bulkheart veteran joanna joyce from
switzerland where they found that there
is a big heterogeneity of macrophages
and
both microglia and monoxide microphages
reside in glioblastoma biology
what i think is relevant well we drive
our research is basically trying to
identify
how does the macrophage and piece of
phenotype
changes in each subtype of
a idh multi-glioblastoma mesenchymal
classical intra-neurons
thank you now we have time for a few
more questions but i want to let our
audience know that any questions we're
unable to answer today
and additionally those questions that
come in during the on-demand
period they will be addressed by our
speaker via the contact information you
provided at the time of registration
okay let's continue how important is
cell differentiation in glioblastoma is
this related to the
different subtypes of glioblastoma
yeah that's something we don't know yeah
that's something
it will be pretty interesting to do
research about that so what we know
is basically uh papers that have been
recently
published uh a couple weeks ago
they basically say that in for example
if we compare
glioblastomas which are idh1 type which
are the ones i talk about it
versus glioblastomas which are idh
mutants which are
a different subset of glioblastoma that
tends to
respond better to some therapies they
are actually very different and the
tissue status is very very different
but where the determinant of this is
totally unknown
and today
thank you now dr galvez casino i'd like
to get your opinion on this
what do you think will be the next
generation of immunotherapies
for glioblastoma against which molecular
targets will these therapies maybe be
directed
okay yeah that's the question we are
asking
every day so what we believe is
basically glioblastomas are highly
infiltrated by mileage cells
so macrophages monocytes
neutrophils etc so what we believe and
today most of the immunotherapies
that are being successful in the clinic
uh have been targeting
t cells so if we want to develop no
immunotherapies for glioblastoma we have
to
move beyond diesels probably and find a
way
to make a space to t cells by
eliminating other type of cells like uh
like mild cells what if we target
macrophages or monocytes with an
antibody that can
deplete these sounds or by targeting
directly the tumor cells and trying to
in some way
deplete these two more cells
thank you and we have time for one more
question
what are the determinant of the
immune infiltration in glioblastoma
how does the tumor mutations play a role
yeah yeah that's that's also very
interesting so we know very few about
that so what we know is from very old
studies
so for example one of the most common
mutations in bioblastoma
is the loss of nf1 which is a key driver
of the animal subjects glioblastoma
and for example just by not having nf1
so glioblastoma cells can recruit
macrophages
that's a very clear example of how a
driver mutation
controls can can be controlled in the
tumor microenvironment
regarding other type of mutations
there's very few that we know
so we which hypothesis that for example
in the case of egfrp3
it could be driving a this response just
because it's uh
it is it acts as a new antigen because
it comes from
uh deletion in the egfr
uh locus that originates a new protein
that
there's no tissue tolerance so it acts
as a new antigen
but regarding like all the limitations
we know very few we
it's not clear how do they influence the
the immunity equation of these tools
thank you dr galvez casino and thank you
for your time today and for your
important research
do you have any final comments for our
audience
yeah no uh i would like to acknowledge
all the
audience i'd like to acknowledge gibko
and mo
fisher for the opportunity also lavrov
for organizing
any other questions i'm happy to to
receive emails or people can follow me
in twitter it's campino
and i'm happy to to answer any other
question
by this media thank you very much
and thank you again and before we go i
would like to thank the audience also
for joining us today and for their
interesting questions
as a reminder those questions we were
unable to answer today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
they will be addressed by dr galvez
casino
via the email address you provided at
the time of registration
i'd also like to thank labrutz and our
sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast today's webcast can be viewed on
demand
and labyrinths will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now we thank you for
joining us
and we hope to see you again soon have a
great day
you